let me but you got in here sixteen I
think it might be good to have a doctor
look at you sometime might be good to
have doctor with it you sometime
ain't got no Burton cuz I was covered
you may have heard there was a prison
break
it was Bonnie and Clyde governor this
has to end
they've committed dozens of armed
robberies and several cold-blooded
murders what do you plan to do about
Bonnie and Clyde we will capture them
write that down and underline it twice
there's only one man who can take them
down I'll come back hey you got a room
for one more night you packed
ah judas priest get in
this is 1934 gangsters submachine guns
and you put Cowboys on Bonnie and Clyde
Texas Rangers forgive me Father for I
have seen this is a highly coordinated
operation so much pain and suffering
roadblocks air surveillance your time
has passed cowboy world coming to
needs to be and have talent to get
published now all you gotta do is shoot
she used her foot to turn him over so he
could see what was about to happen
pack sweet
[Music]
this has gone far enough I'm gonna take
them down
what a fine idea
who are you fella
those were the bad guys
come to the wrong place mister around
here cloud is key
ride might be king but I'm a Texas
Ranger you little [ __ ] now it didn't see
me
you